[Music]
Now,
of course, I think that forgetting the lyrics during the performance is absolutely
wrong.
I do it very quickly.
[Laughs]
Greetings like this seem to make me very happy at the beginning of the day.
[Music] So
today, Shio wears that long skirt. It's
modern, but it also
looks like it's decorated very well. It's a
style I like.  Then I
chose it. I
think Sena knows the style that suits her well.
Uh, that's right,
I don't have one.  Lee didn't
do it the best, but lately Siwoo gets a little more
laid back.
Actually, I thought everyone was like this.
[Laughs]
[Music]
I borrow a lot and I borrow a lot
The reason why I saw myself as an older sister is because we are
roommates, so we borrow and borrow unnie’s clothes.  I
tried it on. I actually
don't have many members who borrow my clothes.
So, among them, the
ones I borrowed
were kind and warm.
[Music] [
Applause]
I think we tend to fall asleep quickly and wake up
early.  [
Music] I
sleep late, so I
thought we mixed well,
but [Music] [Laughs] That's
right, I just go in
without getting out of bed.  I
keep
picturing the bed in my head.  It's
curry made by me,
but both of them
[laugh]
The feeling is so different. If this
was a slightly eventful curry, this is mom
[Music] I
want to eat something stimulating like an event, so
I'm late.
So,
I chose my sister. And
when cooking once, there
are so many spice points. The four of us eat, and
everyone, please come to my house.
Actually, I have something to say.
These days,
Siwoo is my brother, ah, that's right, unexpectedly,
Ara-nim is
really bad.  I'm watching it,
I need to watch it too. Thank you too. Today,
I watch a lot of tae dramas with a
bit of a bit of a
[ __ ].
It's a really good word with me, but the
sound is so different when we're in the same room.
[Music] I
felt that Senna loves animals like a real baby, the
only one raising animals, so I thought about it.
But
when I saw a cat move like this,
I thought that I love animals very much. That's right, I think my horse raises animals.
Also, like my sister, Aran
has a lot of videos, and if
there is a cat passing by on the street, I can
take my eyes off it even for an hour.  I can't help but
keep looking at you like this. I
felt it. What Aran definitely felt is that
when he sees a cat and when he sees me, his
eyes look so different. I
love Siwoo the same way.
[Music] [
Applause] [
Music]
[Music]